ich habe denen wagner ist man da schon
ein ganzes stückchen weiter das land
stufte stuften nämlich cupid 19 nicht
länger als gesellschaftskritische
krankheit an es war ein fast alle
maßnahmen weg unsere reporterin klarer
marie becker hat in dänemark die neue
freiheit für uns entdeckt
weg mit den masken werk mit den
abstandsregeln zurück in die normalität
in dänemark gibt es seit dem ersten
februar quasi keine corona
beschränkungen mehr
shoppen bahnfahren kaffeetrinken in bars
und clubs feiern all das geht ab jetzt
wieder ohne maske und ohne impfnachweis
denn dänemark feiert den freedom day 2.0
in kopenhagen fehlt jetzt schon jegliche
spur von der pandemie fast so als hätte
es coruna nie gegeben die dänische
regierung hat coop 19 ende januar als
nicht mehr gesellschaftskritische
krankheit eingestuft und den zweiten
freedom day angekündigt denn heute heute
abend ist ein meilenstein
wir sind hier mit unglaublich guten
nachrichten wir können jetzt die letzten
corona virus beschränkungen in dänemark
aufheben die freude bei vielen dingen
ist groß und jeder freut sich auf etwas
ganz anderes am meisten eine sache über
die ich auf jeden fall glücklich bin
dass meine gesichtserkennung auf dem
iphone wieder funktioniert natürlich die
machten dass sie abnehmen können ohne
direkt auf geführt zu haben dass wir
nicht dürfen das ist wahrscheinlich das
schönste für mich
ich werde auf jeden fall feiern dieses
wochenende und ab jetzt auch wieder wann
immer es geht ich habe das gefühl dass
es hieß mal dabei bleibt es fühlt sich
anders an dem diesmal sind wirklich alle
beschränkungen aufgehoben es fühlt sich
nach veränderung an
im oktober wurde in dänemark der erste
freedom day gefeiert über den winter
führte die regierung wegen der erneut
steigenden infektionszahlen dann aber
wieder viele regeln ein zum beispiel die
sperrstunde um 23 uhr
die inzidenz in dänemark ist nach wie
vor sehr hoch aber mehr als 81 prozent
der dänen sind vollständig geimpft und
die omikron variante gilt als relativ
harmlos jedes mal als ich heute ein
geschäft ein café eine bar betreten habe
habe ich gemerkt dass meine hand direkt
in die tasche gegriffen hat und nicht
die maske rausholen wollte und jedes mal
war ich so erleichtert darüber dass sich
die nicht aufsetzen muss das ist ja auch
das was uns viele dänen heute
beschrieben haben sie freuen sich darauf
keine maske mehr tragen zu müssen sie
freuen sich darauf wieder feiern gehen
zu können trotzdem muss man sagen die
euphorie über den freedom day die hat
sich hier in grenzen vielleicht liegt es
daran dass sie denn ja auch schon einen
film der im oktober hinter sich haben
danach kam die korona beschränkungen
noch mal wieder und haben aber auch
viele gesagt sie haben vertrauen und
freuen sich darauf und sind der meinung
dieses mal wird es dabei bleiben
freedom day also in dänemark in
deutschland sieht es anders aus aber
warum ist die deutsche politik
eigentlich so starrsinnig alles
orientiert sich weiterhin am instanz
wert und der wurde ja eigentlich schon
im herbst für überholt erklärt das
wollen wir jetzt besprechen mit dem
virologen klaus stöhr guten tag herr
stöhr wir wollen erster welche
aussagekraft hat die sieben tage
incidents überhaupt noch in dieser phase
der pandemie für viele die in der
bevölkerung noch sehr besorgt sind
offensichtlich doch sie hatten ja vor
noch leute und der liebende interviewt
für mich eigentlich gar nicht mehr und
da gibt es viele gründe dafür die erste
grund ist der es gibt ja keine
bekämpfungsmaßnahmen die man an der
inzidenz auch noch fest macht also egal
in welche richtung die sich bewegt die
maßnahmen in den bundesländern in den
regierungsbezirken hängen ja an der
ampel spezialisierung index
hauptsächlich daran und deswegen spielt
es eigentlich gar keine rolle mehr der
zweite grund warum die dann eigentlich
schon lange überlebt es nicht nur als
alleiniger indikator jetzt auch als ein
indikator ist dass sie auch gar nicht
mehr die genauigkeit hat die wir
eigentlich erwarten müssen jetzt kommen
die krankheit über 50 prozent der
patienten mit einem zufallsbefund corona
die sind also nicht wegen corona dort
sondern mit corona das verbessern sind
indikator incident noch stärker und dann
muss man auch davon ausgehen dass die
berechnungsgrundlage auch nicht mehr
existiert dass der dritte grund der
diese inzidenz verbunden hat mit den
danach folgenden
einweisen und in den krankenhäusern war
er vorher berechneten war kein wunder
sagen okay institutionen so hoch 0,5
prozent werden danach von denen die
krank werden und positiv sind ins
krankenhaus kommen und dann 0,6 prozent
auf die intensivstation
diese ganze berechnungsgrundlage fehler
so der japaner ist nicht mehr an die
bekämpfung gebunden das zweite ist er
ist wird immer ungenauer weil das virus
zirkuliert und das wird es wir haben die
brechen grundlagen auch die nicht mehr
als vorher vorhersagewert zu verwenden
also aus meinem blickwinkel geschafft
werden das heißt dann an welchen werten
sollte man sich stattdessen orientieren
irgendeinen wert braucht man ja oder
ihrer meinung nach gar nicht für mich
ein bisschen immer wieder filme und ewig
grüßt das murmeltier in der pandemie
bekämpfung das habe ich immer wieder
gesagt geht es um die krankheitslast
also wie viele leute werden dann
tatsächlich schwerer erkranken können
nicht mehr arbeiten gehen nicht zu hause
bleiben müssen ins krankenhaus das ist
das eigentliche wichtige der wichtige
indikator natürlich kommt man sich dann
noch mal an wie viele leute sind dann
werden positiv wenn man dann noch zurück
rechnen kann aber die krankheitslast ist
das entscheidende peter regierungsrat
einweisungen in die krankenhäuser auch
die altersstruktur derjenigen die in die
krankenhäuser kommen und danach
natürlich die frage wie ist die
intensivstation
bewegung durch corona patienten und dann
die tolles wort also das sind die drei
wichtigsten indikatoren und dahinter
liegt natürlich die frage wie pathogener
die krank machen ist das virus an sich
und da sehen wir jetzt dass durch das
entspannt hat es gibt also weniger
häufig schwerer verläuft durch diese
sollte die neue variante also all das
passt alles zusammen
und jetzt muss auch die politik
reagieren für mich ist ja nicht nur
erstaunlich dass man in deutschland
nicht reagiert und das man im prinzip
passt
gesamten europäischen ausland sich
entweder pläne und machst oder die pläne
auch ganz radikalen umsetzt ist ja nicht
nur dänemark es ist ja auch finnland das
den wm in england irland
in anderen ländern wird auch stufenweise
genug ist ja richtig mal deutlich alles
auf das geht auch jetzt nicht in
deutschland gibt es noch sehr viele
ungeimpfte und gewisse sorgfaltspflicht
hat ja start natürlich auch für
diejenigen die sich freiwillig halt
nicht impfen lassen das ist absolut
völlig unbesehen und dann muss auch die
maßnahmen sicherlich in den altenpflege
einem aufrechterhalten gerade in der
stationären auf einem mobilen
krankenpflege aber sagt man jetzt zweig
plus und 2g belässt das ist für mich
nicht nachvollziehbar
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung dazu
an den virologen cluster ich bedanke
mich